Pam ball
try to smooth of the second age I'd
heard the stories but I remember my name
now my name is Alistair Duncan and I
play Calabria more in the shadow of
mordor I'm Troy Baker and I play tallien
in shadow of Laura what's so interesting
about the character playing it was
actually that that level of mystery that
my character has the void of discovery
that the players gonna go on with my
character through the game and with
Italian and you know Italian is is first
resurrected it's this where am i what is
happening and the one person that can
answer that is this Spectre if what you
say is true then how do we breakfast
goes we find the one who cast upon us we
are very separate characters in this but
our characters are melded at times the
interesting part was when we're separate
we're actually in either in conflict or
trying to make a plan or moving forward
through something or discovering things
about ourselves I think there were
challenges with developing the
characters individually and also how
those two will work in concert with each
other because not only narrative lis but
also systemically we have to establish
that and you never want to do anything
that from a narrative aspect doesn't
support game play and then in turn you
also want to make sure that the gameplay
is in stark contrast to the story so it
was something that very early on this
relationship is really kind of the core
of the story these are the two people
that take you through this journey it
will be more battles Charlie
but we will find out please the one of
the thing is that the voice that the
player goes on is a void we go on we are
we're actually that's it
we get a we get a we get to find these
things out and we have to do together
even if we don't like each other and
then we end up as a team it's it's very
cool
Sauron knows we're here
that's no keep him waiting